there's a study just came out of barna
barnes i guess it came out a little
while ago but it's making the rounds
again because of these new laws
30 percent of millennials identify as
lgbtq whatever the rest of the letters
are
40 of zoomers the younger generation
identify as lgbtq whatever the rest of
the letters are
when you just look at the general
population
identification with lgbtq lmnop
is six
percent so how did we go
and it's much lower among certain age
groups so how do we go from six percent
to forty percent
what the
left used to tell you is look you're
just born this way you're born this way
you can never change your sexual desires
or orientation or then later gender
right you can't change it
now they now it's a little different
because they're saying not only can you
change your sexual desires you can
change your whole sex if you're a man
you can become a woman but so it's a
little bit confused
but the one thing we were told
is that none of this has anything to do
with culture
none of this has anything to do with
nurture none of this has anything to do
with education
can't change who we it's just who we are
is just deep deep deep down
so my question then is how did we go
from six percent to 40
either
alex jones is right and there's just
something in the water and they're not
only turning the frickin frogs gay but
they're turning everyone else gay too i
it's either that
oh and actually he was right about the
frog so i don't know all right i'll uh
withhold judgment
or what i think is probably more likely
culture obviously matters and culture
shapes
the way and education most importantly
shapes the way we view the world shapes
the way we view ourselves it even helps
to shape our desires
right little kids desire to just eat
cookies all the time and have no
self-control
and then through education as they grow
and mature their tastes change their
desires change and their discipline
changes
as well
or at least it used to now we put
education completely in the opposite
direction
to uh not to cultivate the higher things
in the rational will but to cultivate
all sorts of crazy beyond sex just to
cultivate all sorts of crazy crazy sorts
of desires
if that is the case
that the culture and the education
shapes it
then obviously
we've got to have a say in education
then obviously
if education
could
convince a
half a generation of of americans that
they're not the sex that they say that
they are
they're they're not the sex that they
actually are and they're a com
completely different sex or their sexual
desires are all kind of kooky if it can
do that then it can go in the other
direction too can it
the
i'm actually not even all that surprised
by these very high numbers 30 40 percent
what this tells me is that young people
are right now as they always are
searching for meaning they're searching
for truth they're very confused they
don't have all the answers and they're
just trying to grab on to the things
that are deeper not merely the physical
things of this world but what's it all
about what are we here for what am i you
know all the questions the young people
ask
and they
used to
have those questions answered by by true
religion and by true philosophy and by
sophisticated serious thinking
and now they're having those questions
answered by radical leftist ideologues
who are extremely shallow in their
thought and who are leading them down a
very bad path
and telling them actually all you all
you are is
your appetites
all you are
is either your flesh or not your flesh
all you they're they're
not getting very good answers there and
we and
young people have a right to the truth
and we ought to present it to them in
schools glad you liked that clip
ring the bell please
ring the bell
subscribe get notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe there to the michael knowles
show leave a five star review we
probably just put up ten you know leave
two five star reviews if you can i don't
know i don't really know how it works
subscribe we will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you